[Music]
we will be issuing document requests to
over 60 different people and individuals
from the White House to the Department
of Justice Donald Trump jr. Alan why
Solberg to begin the investigations to
present the case that American people
about about obstruction of justice
corruption and abusive past I can walk
right all the time with everybody it's a
political hoax
Nadler is setting the framework now that
the Democrats are not to believe the
Moller report they're now saying we have
to do our own investigation
well it's 81 individuals agencies
entities tied to President Trump
received a flurry of letters demanding
documents today as a part of these
increasing Democratic probes take a look
at some of them 25 of the 81 individuals
getting these letters today from the
Judiciary Committee under Democrat
control the ranking member on that
committee Doug Collins issued a
statement we don't even know what the
Muller report says the Democrats are
already hedging their bets after
recklessly prejudging the president for
obstruction
chairman Nadler is pursuing evidence to
back up his conclusion because as he
admits we don't have the facts yet we'll
start there with the news of the day
what's bring in our panel Kristen
Walters politics editor here at Fox News
Katie Pavlich is news editor at
townhall.com and Jim Messina Democratic
strategist and CEO of the Messina group
okay Jim you know when you listen to
Nadler over the weekend on the sunday
shows and he said I've reached the
conclusion that the president has
obstructed justice and then the
follow-up is well why not move forward
with impeachment now and he says well we
have to lay out the case to the American
people what do you think of that
is it cart before the horse look I think
it's smart Democrats are being very
careful politically they've learned some
lessons from the Republicans in the 90s
when they impeach President Clinton they
don't want to go down that road yet they
want to build a very compelling case
this is not surprising I was the White
House deputy chief of staff for
President Obama when the Republicans
took over the house the very first day I
got a bunch of these same letters and
same lawyers calling me saying we're
gonna look
this stuff it's it's balance of power
and the house is gonna look very deeply
into stuff and they should 34 members of
President Trump's campaign or a close
circle have been indicted and we should
look at it okay well they should have
learned some lessons about in Patriot
but it seems like the ball has been
moved completely off of the field when
it comes to what Democrats have acted
like they want to know first it was they
wanted to know all about Russian
collusion which is why they supported
the Moller probe and then they
criticized anyone who dared to go after
a question the credibility of Robert
Moeller and the people who had working
with him in fact we haven't heard calls
for a while about passing legislation to
protect the Special Counsel
investigation now that Democrats don't
seem to be getting what they want when
it comes to information that they can
use for impeachment there is a proper
role for Congress to play when it comes
to oversight however this is not about
investigating government scandals like
Operation Fast and Furious or the IRS
targeting targeting conservatives this
is about going after President Trump
personally and using Congress in
subpoena House committees with subpoenas
to open up a treasure trove of
opposition research for 2022 candidate
candidates and the truth is that
impeachment might be good in the primary
but it's not going to be good in a
general election that's really the
question because it is a political
process I mean this is not a criminal
endeavor it's a political process if you
look at the latest NBC Wall Street
Journal poll on the president's job
performance it's actually ticked up from
January from 43 to 46 percent
disapproval 52 Chris and is there a
risk/reward moment here for Democrats
where they have to decide do we go down
this road fully or do we look to make
our mark legislative don't under
don't under appreciated agree to which
of waiting another government shutdown
works for trumps favor and don't also
under appreciate the degree to which
having to focus on Democrats whether
they be in Virginia or whether it be the
green New Deal or it has not been a run
of good weeks for Democrats in terms of
the narrative I would say keep a prayer
and keep some sympathy for Jerry Nadler
he's a serious person trying to do a
serious job but he has on his committee
and he has among the Democratic
conference people who want to be much
more radical and much more aggressive
than he is so he's riding a tiger here
he needs to show his members yep I'm on
the case we're being diligent we're
being
aggressive but he wants to keep them at
bay so that they don't do what Katie's
talking about where you end up Nancy
Pelosi Jerry Nadler do not want to
impeach Donald Trump unless they
absolutely have to they'd rather just
meet him in 2020
all right here's Jerry Nadler on that
very question on the Muller
investigation crimes and impeachable
offenses two different things
they can be crimes that are not
impeachable offenses and impeachable
offenses and not crimes they're just two
different tests but we have to lay out
for the American people and we can't
depend on the modern investigation for
this the mobile investigation number one
we don't know when is ending despite
lots of rumors number two it's it's
focused on specific crimes does it sound
to you Jim that they have a feeling that
Muller's not going to deliver what they
want it to deliver
well I think is interesting everyone's
already on both sides deciding what the
Muller report is going to before we see
and it hasn't even been out why don't we
all just sit back let the Muller report
come out and then figure out what to do
next I think now there's right that the
obstruction stuff having posta Muller
it's not in the Muller report it's a
different set of questions that they're
gonna look at but let's wait for Muller
to come here well we say that all the
time in the panel we don't know we don't
know we're gonna wait and see and it
could happen soon but we would not put a
date on it there are other things going
on the Southern District of New York
there are other investigations and we
point that out as well kidding yeah I
mean there's there's plenty that we do
not know and Republicans or Democrats
should not decide what they think is
going to be in them in the Moller probe
but the problem for Democrats is they
have put everything on this we've been
hearing about Russian collusion for
months that there was evidence of this
which is why Robert Moeller had to be
protected of course that's exactly what
he's investigating collusion the fact is
that Robert Muller actually isn't
investigating collusion because
collusion isn't a crime under the
statutes that he's investigating like
conspiracy conspiracy but people are
using the word collusion in the legal
sense that the terms very much matter
when it comes to the subpoenas that are
being issued it's not about corruption
in the government in corruption in
Washington DC these are about personal
entities of the president they want as
tax returns they want to go after Ivanka
Trump they want to go after after Donald
Trump jr. they are going into every
single personal issue that the President
may have that they can use on the
campaign trail against him to beat him
in 2020 so when it
hums that line it's going to be
interesting to see how much Democrats
can get done legislatively when all of
their time is being spent investigating
personal finances of a president that
they simply don't like there are some
investigations like the emoluments
clause and whether the president is
using his office in some way shape or
form to make money where the two
intersect to the personal and the the
president currently I want to turn
quickly to the emergency declaration
Rand Paul coming out saying he's gonna
vote against this this resolution he's
going to vote for the resolution that
says there should not be a national
emergency declaration by the president I
think it's easy to argue that this
emergency order this executive order
goes against the will of Congress not
all Congress but the majority of
Congress that passed the appropriation
bill I spoke to the president last night
and we had a good discussion he says he
understands where I'm coming from and he
didn't tell me would never play golf
again so I don't know it isn't about
President Trump it's about the division
of power for me and there are four
Republicans now saying that they are
against the president saying there
should be an emergency declaration on
the border the problem here for them and
for Democrats who support this measure
is that the president's already
threatened to veto it and they're just
not going to have 67 votes in the Senate
well first of all sweet vest Rand Paul
very solid but number two this matters
in a legal sense because as you go to
court the president asked five times
Congress give me the money for the thing
that I want five times Congress said no
and then they're gonna come back and say
and we specifically denounced the
activity that you're taking that look
he's gonna veto it and he's gonna go on
ahead but as the courts look at this
matter it's not going to be ambiguous
what Congress thinks about the
president's decision here the other
thing is this is a first this will be
the first time that Republicans in
Congress have given Trump the the yank
they've said absolutely not we're not
going to do it that five will be 10 I'm
sure by the time they're done
Mitt Romney Ben Sasse Mike Lee and
others I'm sure who stand up for
separation of powers again this isn't
about the issue it's not about what you
think it's about the division of